I think there are two problems here one
is that the uh there are some things
that can be fought on an individual
basis like here's what I can do but
there are other things in a police state
is one of them it requires institutional
coordination the way you block a police
state is you have a Supreme Court ruling
that strikes down this nefarious
alliance between the government and the
digital platforms often operating
operating by the way through
intermediaries you know nonprofit groups
academics and so on the courts need to
do that uh and then you need you know
the Republic in Congress to do things
and uh you need Attorneys General to do
things I mean it would it would send a
shock wave through the Democrats if you
had if you suddenly had Republican Das
in Texas in Florida and elsewhere
indicting major figures of the
democratic party for crimes that are
occurring in their states so legitimate
prosecutions but if none of those
occur so I want to get into obviously
police state and and what it's about and
yes it does feel like many of us who
have warned about a whole bunch of this
kind of as I said to Ben Shapiro on my
live stream this morning it feels like
in some ways like we failed like we were
yelling about a lot of this but maybe we
didn't do enough to stop some of it
let's say but before we dive into into
that fully I thought maybe we could just
talk about just generally what's going
on in the world at the moment because it
is a crazy world and uh what do you make
of sort of where we're at what's going
on obviously in the Middle East what
America's role is supposed to be I'm
just tossing a wide one at you we'll go
there well the um I think this the the
attack by Hamas and the fact that it was
not only missed by Israeli intelligence
which is something to be examined within
Israel but clearly missed also by us
intelligence and now let's flash back to
post 911 when many people I mean me
included were like listen there's
something that's going on within Islam
you've got this emergence of this of
radical Islam
uh and it has become militant in a way
that we haven't seen before maybe it all
started with the Ki Revolution but you
see this militancy within the Shia and
Sunni strains of Islam both okay we got
to give a lot of these new surveillance
Powers we need to collapse some of the
old distinctions between intelligence
gathering and let's say criminal
prosecution because we're not just
trying to wait for a crime and then go
chase who did it we're trying to prevent
a crime from occurring before it does
but we warrant even then and this is a
case where some of the Libertarians the
sort of the ran Pauls and Ron Pauls of
the world were like guys if you give
this power to the federal government
they not only can but they will abuse it
right that that sort of gets us to your
movie but we right yeah so that's one
phase of the whole thing I think that's
really interesting the other phase that
interests me as someone who's written
about education about the campus is how
you have these guys who have been
delicate flowers on the campus you know
don't offend me don't trigger me I can't
hear an opinion I disagree with
microaggressions make sure you get my
pronouns right and then when you get a
mass attack with all this these
atrocities they seem to be politically
okay with it uh they'll say well we're
not defending Hamas we're defending
Palestine but clearly they are okay with
in the name of decolonization and in the
name of resistance they tie their own
domestic causes in with the cause of
Hamas yeah do you see that that tie-in
and how quickly BLM sort of flipped into
what I would argue is really a pramas
movement the the distinction I can't
make that distinction because I don't
see anyone on the ground making that
distinction right at these rallies you
don't see anyone out there going no no
I'm for Palestine I'm against Hamas it's
not no I mean look at the beam could
have posted a Palestinian child with big
eyes but they posted the the Hamas
terrorist coming in on a glider so so
what do you make of how that has now
been exported into the United States and
it does seem you know we always use the
word systemic related to everything it
does seem systemic and that it doesn't
seem organic that these protests
happened the what might some might call
an Insurrection at the capital in the
last couple of days Etc I mean I've been
struck by the fact uh that the left is a
global movement the right is not a
global movement the right tends to be
confined within each country now there
are some links that are beginning to
emerge because people see The Echoes
right I mean you had this quote
Insurrection on January 6th we saw
something almost identical in Brazil
right um when you think about coid
restrictions for example restrictions on
religious liberty on right to assembly
yes you saw them in America but then hey
they're in Canada hey they're in
Australia they're in New Zealand they're
all over Europe so suddenly and I and I
actually raised this in the film I say
wait police state yes but police Planet
maybe because now you're beginning to
see a global movement pushing kind of in
the same direction I think that also
applies to the um to the sort of Hamas
BLM Alliance the left here draws energy
from from similar forces abroad and vice
versa I don't know if you saw the Hamas
leader he's like talking about George
Floyd yeah no it's incredible he said
this is our George Floyd moment right do
you think we have the right apparatus or
the right fortitude to fight this I mean
it it seems like things keep sliding
somewhat in the wrong direction I keep
telling people like I'm very bullish on
the State of Florida that's where I live
you're in Texas obviously some good
things are happening there but the
country as a whole seems very very
wounded at least with the leadership we
have right now and the agencies I think
there are two problems here one is that
the uh there are some things that can be
fought in an individual basis like
here's what I can do but there are other
things in the police state is one of
them it requires institutional
coordination the way you block a police
state is you have a Supreme Court ruling
that strikes down this nefarious
alliance between the government and the
digital platforms often Opera operating
by the way through intermediaries you
know nonprofit groups academics and so
on the courts need to do that uh and
then you need you know the Republican
Congress to do things and uh you need
Attorneys General to do things I mean it
would it would send a shock wve through
the Democrats if you had if you suddenly
had Republican Das in Texas in Florida
and elsewhere indicting major figures of
the democratic party for crimes that are
occurring in their states so legitimate
prosecutions but if none of those occur
so what would be a prosecution that well
let's take let's take an example I'm
just playing the game the Democrats play
so for example
Texas there is open child trafficking
going on across the border the Biden
Administration is well aware of it to
them it's a casualty of what they want
to achieve which is they want to bring
all these people over here they know
that this empowers cartels they know
that these kids because a lot of these
adults come in with a kid you know
here's here's a dependent child but it's
not their kid and so the kid goes into
basically a child trafficking operation
because the child trafficking operations
volunteer to quote adopt these kids this
is by the way all in the movie and so
the Biden Administration is yeah that's
ugly stuff and we're not we don't intend
that but it's an acceptable consequence
of what you're doing well imagine for
example if the Texas Attorney General
and you can even do this in locally
indict mayorcas or or bring an
indictment for knowing participation in
criminal and illegal sex trafficking and
child trafficking so it's interesting
because it's one of the things that I've
been bringing up on the show a lot
lately which is that the Democrats seem
so negligent when it comes to the border
that it can be it can't be negligence
that it must be intentional that's
basically what you're saying I think now
we're getting into this weird spot with
Rashida TB where it's almost like we
have a we have an agent in the
Democratic party how do you blend that
as someone that just made a movie called
police state out out this very week out
on locals and in theaters how do you
blend doing the right thing without then
becoming part of the police state where
you're taking out people who you know
maybe you disagree with no I mean I I
agree and I I I don't think that the
advice that we should do exactly what
they do because if they do Lawless stuff
I'm not saying we should do Lawless
stuff but I'm saying that there is
something invertebrate about the
Republicans and and somewhat even the
conservatives which is when you say
things like I can't do what the other
side is doing I'm standing on principle
I'm better than that this is actually
the staple rhetoric of right the right
of
center that is dependent on a context
that um I think is no longer our context
so you know think of the think the movie
uh you know Jimmy Stewart and The Man
Who Shot Liberty Balance and he's this
very uh straight laac lawyer yeah and
his basic idea is you know we have to
believe in the law we don't believe in
the law of the Jungle so I'm not going
to go get a gun I have a law book and if
something happens to me I'm going to
like call in the authorities reported to
the sheriff now if you're in a small
town with a decent sheriff and an
infrastructure of that that is the way
to go that's the way I want to live on
the other hand if you take a covered
wagon and go out west and you suddenly
realize I that Outlaws have encircled
your Ranch and they've got all these
long guns and they want to burn your
homestead and rape your wife take your
kids and if you say I'm not going to go
for my rifle because you know I don't
want to be like them and you know I'm
I'm better than that I'm a man of
principle I mean you don't even know
what to say to such a person because
they have no appreciation of the gravity
of the situation and the fact that
you're in a combat zone and you need to
act at least start with the psychology
of that and then decide how you should
respond if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell